quel bilan pouvons nous faire
aujourd'hui de la situation
la phrase vous le savez affronte une
deuxième vague épidémique extrêmement
forte qui touche tout aussi durban
l'ensemble de nos voisins européens
comme nous l'avions annoncé l'impact
sanitaire de l'épidémie reste très lourd
le nombre de décès continue d'augmenter
au cours des deux derniers mois nous
avons connu plus de dix mille décès
supplémentaires dus à la covin 19
portant le nombre total de personnes
décédées à quarante deux mille cinq cent
depuis le début de la pandémie au cours
de la dernière semaine entre 400 et 500
personnes sont mortes chaque jour là que
vit cela veut dire qu'aujourd'hui en
france
un décès sur quatre est due au virus
au-delà de ces chiffres il s'agit de
femmes et d'hommes il s'agit de vies
brisées par la maladie il s'agit de la
douleur de milliers de familles
auxquelles je veux dire ma solidarité et
mon émotion dans l'épreuve qui les
frappe
deuxième élément de constats sur la
situation sanitaire
la pression sur notre système
hospitalier s'est fortement accrue et
mais nos soignants dans une tension
extrême
l'ambiance d'anticiper tout l'enjeu et
d'y faire face
avec une seule exigence pouvoir soigner
toutes celles et ceux qui en ont besoin
et éviter à tout prix
le drame de prise en charge dégradée
comme nous pouvons l'observer par
exemple en italie depuis quelques jours
nous comptons ces derniers jours une
hospitalisation toutes les 30 secondes
et une admission en réanimation toutes
les 3 minutes 40 % 40 % des personnes
admises en réanimation ont moins de 65
ans
c'est évidemment considérable et nous
avons dépassé en nombre
d'hospitalisations le pic du mois
d'avril
aujourd'hui ce sont 4 1803 malades de
l'aco vide qui sont pris en charge en
réanimation ce qui représente 95% de nos
capacités normales de lits de
réanimation
or crise pour pouvoir faire face à cet
afflux
nous avons armée au cours des deux
dernières semaines
mille trois cent soixante lits
supplémentaires afin d'accueillir plus
de malades de la coved mais aussi
d'autres malades qui doivent être prises
en charge pour d'autres motifs
nous pourrions aller jusqu'à dix mille
quatre cents lits si cela était
nécessaire puisque nous nous sommes
préparés au cours des derniers mois pour
faire face à une vague de grande ampleur
je veux dire ici une nouvelle fois toute
mon admiration à nos professionnels de
santé ils sont à l'épreuve
ils sont fatigués mais je les observe
très directement au fil de mes
déplacements réguliers dans nos
établissements de santé ils sont
remarquables de compétences d'engagement
et de solidarité
tout le monde est sur le pont les
établissements publics les
établissements privés les professionnels
libéraux
les personnels de l'ensemble des
administrations sanitaires
ces soignants ils ne nous demandent pas
d'augmenter le nombre de lits de
réanimation
ne serait ce que parce qu'ils savent
bien que formé un médecin réanimateur ou
une infirmière spécialisée ne peut pas
se faire en six mois ils nous demandent
surtout de tout mettre en oeuvre pour
éviter que les malades arrivent à
l'hôpital
quel bilan pouvons nous faire de la mise
en oeuvre des mesures de confinement
depuis le 30 octobre
vous le savez nous n'avons pas souhaité
reproduire le confinement du printemps
dernier qui s'était traduit par une mise
à l'arrêt brutal de la vie économique
sociale
et éducative de notre pays les effets
que nous pouvons mesurer sont à ce jour
cohérent avec ce que nous recherchions
un confinement adapté qui cherchent à
limiter au maximum tous les déplacements
non essentiels mais qui préserve
l'éducation de nos enfants est limite
autant que possible ses impacts sur
l'emploi et sur l'économie
quelques chiffres nous observons une
réduction très forte des déplacements
depuis deux semaines les déplacements
entre le domicile et le travail sont
inférieures de 22% à ce qu'ils étaient
en septembre dernier la fréquentation
des moyens de transport collectif a
fortement baissé moins 55% dans le métro
à paris par exemple
c'est aussi le cas des déplacements
longue distance puisque le réseau aérien
domestique est à 10 % de ses capacités
normales
tandis que les déplacements en train
longue distance ont chuté de 85%
ces chiffres s'expliquent par la
limitation de nos déplacements non
professionnels mais aussi par un recours
accru au télétravail qui a fortement
progressé au cours des deux dernières
semaines
45 % des salariés privés ont télétravail
et au cours de la semaine écoulée pour
une durée moyenne de 3,7 jours dans la
semaine mais nous pouvons encore
progresser
la ministre elisabeth bornes y reviendra
ce recours aux accrue au télétravail
accompagne une stratégie de confinement
qui place la sécurité sanitaire au
premier plan tout en essayant de
préserver l'activité économique et donc
l'emploi
de ce point de vue les dernières données
de la banque de france montrent que
l'activité économique pourrait baisser
de 12% au mois de novembre
c'est un choc important mais c'est trois
fois moins qu'au printemps dernier
quel est l'impact de ce confinement sur
l'épidémie nous constatons que
l'évolution du nombre de nouvelles
contaminations s'est ralenti depuis une
semaine
si l'on raisonne en moyenne sur 7 jours
nous observons une baisse de l'ordre de
16%
cette évolution doit être interprétée de
manière positive mais prudente positive
car elle traduit une inflexion et c'est
ce que nous espérions positive car cette
tendance si elle se confirme indiquerait
que ce qu'on appelle le taux de
reproduction du virus
le fameux air est passé en dessous de 1
pour se situer entre 0,8 et 0,9 mais
prudente car cette tendance récente donc
fragile et ne peut produire des
résultats que si elle se confirme dans
la durée prudente
enfin car nous ne voyons pas encore
l'impact de cette évolution sur les
hospitalisations alors que c'est
fondamentalement notre objectif
l'enseignement que je tire de ces
différents éléments et que notre
stratégie de confinement fondé sur un
équilibre différent qu'en mars dernier
semble produire les premiers effets
attendus même si nous devons rester je
voulais dit très prudent nous pouvons
tirer de cela trois autres conclusions
la première est qu'il serait
irresponsable de lever ou même d'alléger
le dispositif dès maintenant nous avons
dans un cadre concerté avec la
communauté éducative adapter les règles
dans les lycées afin d'y accroître le
respect de la sécurité sanitaire
le ministre chargé de l'éducation
nationale jean michel blanquer rire
viendra avec le président de la
république
nous avons donc décidé ce matin de
maintenir
changer au moins pour les 15 prochains
jours
les règles du confinement les commerces
fermés au titre du confinement le
resteront donc encore pour 15 jours
supplémentaires
je sais ce qu elle angoisse des
commerçants qui n'aspire qu'à pouvoir
travailler et sont très inquiets de ne
pouvoir rouvrir à ses taux avant les
fêtes de fin d'année notre objectif est
bien de pouvoir y parvenir
mais ce moment n'est pas encore venu
cette décision je la prends en
responsabilité elle est lourde et
difficile mais mon rôle n'est pas
aujourd'hui dans le sens de la facilité
de céder à la pression de faire ce qui
serait espérée par beaucoup et je les
comprends
au risque de tout compromettre et de
nous obliger à refermer dans deux
semaines et peut-être pour tout le mois
de décembre
le deuxième enseignement que je tire est
que nous devons évidemment continuer à
apporter un soutien économique massif à
tous les commerces et toutes les
entreprises qui était qui ont été
contraintes de fermer
j'assume mes responsabilités en termes
de protection contre l'épidémie
j'entends les assumer de la même manière
pour protéger les victimes économiques
du confinement pour les entreprises et
les commerces fermés les dispositifs
dead que nous mettons en place seront
rappelées dans un instant par le
ministre bruno le maire
ils se traduiront par le versement des
premières aides financières au titre de
l'activité partielle ou du fonds de
solidarité de 10000 euros par mois dans
les prochains jours et d'ici la fin du
mois de novembre
à partir d'exemples très concrets le
ministre vous montrera l'impact très
puissant de nos différentes aides pour
couvrir les pertes de chiffre d'affaires
nous avons un objectif tout faire pour
sauver nos petits commerces
notre soutient nous le devons aussi aux
salariés d'abord en prolongeant les
dispositifs de chômage partiel qui ont
permis depuis le printemps de sauver des
emplois et de préserver le pouvoir
d'achat
pour ceux qui ont perdu leur emploi au
cours des derniers mois et notamment
pour les demandeurs d'emploi qui
arrivent en fin de droits tout doit être
fait pour éviter le risque de basculer
dans la précarité
c'est pourquoi j'ai demandé à la
ministre du travail de proposer aux
partenaires sociaux qu'elle réunissait
cet après-midi de reconduire le
dispositif de prolongation
exceptionnelle des droits à l'assurance
chômage pour les chômeurs qui sont
aujourd'hui en fin de droits est ce le
temps du confinement
nous sommes particulièrement attentifs à
la situation d'isolement des plus jeunes
de nos concitoyens et en particulier des
étudiants dont les établissements nonce
n'assurent plus leur enseignement
sauf exception camp distant ciel dans
les prochains jours sur proposition de
la ministre en charge des universités
chacune des huit cents cité
universitaire de france va disposer de
deux référents étudiants qui viendront
renforcer le travail des services des
crous notamment pour accompagner les
étudiants de première année et les
étudiants les plus en difficulté ce sont
près de 1600 emplois étudiants qui
seront ainsi créés sur les mois de
novembre décembre et janvier
dans un contexte où l'emploi étudiant
s'est par ailleurs raréfier
plus généralement nous veillons au
déploiement du plan un jeune une
solution qui mobilise vous le savez une
part importante des crédits du plan de
relance plan de relance plus que jamais
nécessaire pour contrecarrer les effets
nocifs de la crise sanitaire sur la
situation de l'emploi
la troisième et dernière leçon qu'il est
nécessaire de tirer de ce premier bilan
à 15 jours et que l'enjeu des jours qui
viennent est surtout de ne pas relâcher
nos efforts mais de les amplifier
je remercie très sincèrement l'immense
majorité des françaises et des français
qui respecte les règles communes mais
nous constatons dans certaines zones ou
partie du territoire respect encore
insuffisant de ces règles après une
première phase ii nécessaire pédagogie
j'ai donné au ministre de l'intérieur
des consignes de fermeté et lui ai
demandé d'accroître encore la
mobilisation des forces de l'ordre
notamment à paris en ile de france et
dans les grandes métropoles
depuis le 30 octobre les forces de
police et de gendarmerie ont procédé à
près de 580 1000 contrôles qu'en dernier
lieu à 88 1455 verbalisation dont
environ 300 concerne l'ouverture
irrégulières des établissements recevant
du public
au delà des contrôles j'en appelle au
civisme par le respect de ces règles
vous le savez uniquement destiné à
protéger notre santé nous devons rester
constant et cohérent
c'est ce qui nous amène à ne pas faire
évoluer les mesures aujourd'hui je crois
que chacune et chacun le comprendra
pour autant si nous ne modifions pas les
choses aujourd'hui il est important que
nous puissions donner de la visibilité
sur ce qui pourrait se passer au cours
des prochaines semaines et la manière
dont nous allons suivre les indicateurs
pour en tirer les conséquences sur
l'adaptation de nos mesures d'ici la fin
de l'année
nous suivons principalement deux
indicateurs un indicateur de circulation
du virus
c'est le nombre de cas par jour que nous
calculons sur la moyenne des sept
derniers jours pour lisser les
fluctuations d'un jour sur l'autre un
indicateur de pression sur le système
hospitalier
c'est le nombre de patients qu'ovide
hospitalisés en réanimation
comme je voulais indiqué nous observons
depuis une semaine un infléchissement du
nombre de cas positifs
non seulement il a arrêté d'augmenter
mais la courbe marque une tendance à la
baisse autour de 16% sur la dernière
semaine
si la semaine prochaine cette tendance
de se confirmer pas et que le nombre de
patients qu'aux vide en réanimation
devait continuer à augmenter alors nous
serions amenés à prendre des mesures
supplémentaires afin d'arrêter la vague
si au contraire comme nous l'espérons la
tendance observée ces derniers jours se
confiant nous pensons que le pic de la
deuxième vague pourrait être atteint
dans nos hôpitaux
en début de semaine prochaine
comme vous le voyez sur le graphique qui
s'affiche cela signifie qu'à partir de
la semaine prochaine le nombre de
patients que vides en réanimation
pourrait nous l'espérons commencé à
diminuer
ce serait une très bonne nouvelle une
première étape très importante mais qui
ne suffira évidemment pas pour que la
pression sur le système hospitalier
reviennent à des niveaux supportables
si l'augmentation des chiffres des
prochaines semaines confirmait que nous
restons bien en ligne avec cette
perspective des premières mesures
d'allégement pourrait intervenir à
compter du 1er décembre mais elle serait
strictement limitée au commerce que nous
avons dû fermer à partir du confinement
et leur réouverture ne pourrait
s'envisager que sur la base d'un
protocole renforcé que j'ai demandé aux
ministres compétents de concerter avec
les professionnels et de soumettre aux
instances scientifiques
cette première étape ne pourra cependant
pas concerner d'autres établissements
recevant du public où les risques de
contamination sont par nature plus élevé
comme par exemple les bars les
restaurants et les salles de sport bien
entendu pour ces établissements des
mesures de soutien et d'accompagnement
seront main
tenu notre objectif est de pouvoir
permettre un nouvel allègement au moment
des vacances de noël afin que les
français puissent passer des fêtes de
fin d'année en famille mais celles ci ne
pourront pas se tenir de la même manière
que d'habitude on pourra bien sûr se
retrouver avec les siens mais il ne
serait pas raisonnable d'espérer pouvoir
organiser de grandes fêtes à plusieurs
dizaines de personnes notamment pour le
réveillon du 31 décembre
je vais maintenant demander à olivier
véran ministre des solidarités de la
santé de vous présenter un point sur la
situation spital hier et sur l'évolution
de notre stade stratégies de dépistage
par les tests dits antigénique monsieur
le ministre monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames messieurs comme le premier
ministre vient de l'expliquer on voit
depuis une semaine une réduction du
nombre de nouveaux diagnostics quotidien
par rapport aux semaines précédentes et
comme le premier ministre l'a aussi très
bien expliqué pour autant comme il ya un
décalage entre le moment où les
contaminations sont faits a été le
moment où les patients présentent des
formes graves ayant recours donc à
l'hôpital ou au service de réanimation
comme il ya ce décalage ne sommes pas
encore dans une phase de réduction du
nombre d'hospitalisations et d'admission
réanimation donc il n'ya pas de paradoxe
à cela c'est le constat que nous avions
fait déjà au printemps dernier à
l'occasion de la première vague ainsi de
fait la pression sanitaires continuent
d'augmenter sur la médecine de ville sur
les services d'urgence sur les hôpitaux
et sur les réanimations puisque il ya
davantage de patients qui rentre à
l'hôpital est en réanimation qu'il ya
deux patients qui en sortent nous ne
sommes pas donc encore au pic
mais comme le premier ministre l'a dit
nous pourrions atteindre le pic
hospitalier dans les prochains jours en
tout cas nous l'espérons pour pouvoir
faire face à cette pression sanitaires
extrêmement forte notamment sur le
secteur hospitalier
nous poursuivons le développement le
déploiement la préparation des hôpitaux
avec la mobilisation encore une fois
incroyable de l'ensemble des soignants
sur tout le territoire national
il ya ce soir plus de 7700 lit de
rennais de réanimation armée puisque
comme vous le savez en plus des presque
5000 patients qu'aux vide en réanimation
il y à des malades qui sont dans les
service de réa pour d'autres maladies
suite à des interventions chirurgicales
des infarctus des ruptures d'anévrisme
et autres rien que pour la région
auvergne rhône-alpes qui est vous le
savez la région la plus impactée à
l'heure actuelle par l'épidémie c'est
quasiment x 2 en termes de lits de
réanimation on est passé de 600 lits de
réarmer dans cette région a presque 1200
lits armés tout cela ne se fait pas d'un
claquement de doigts et nécessite de
gros efforts au quotidien
le premier effort à réaliser c'est ce
qu'on appelle la déprogrammation des
soins de chirurgie non urgents tout en
pérennisant sanctuary en quelque sorte
la chirurgie en cancérologie l'activité
de greffe ainsi que d'autres chirurgies
absolument indispensable mais donc de
fait un certain nombre de malades qui
devait être opéré sont rappelées dans
différentes régions du territoire pour
leur demander de différer leur
intervention chirurgicale pour garder de
la place disponible pour les malades
atteints du coc vide
c'est également la mobilisation sans
précédent de l'ensemble des soignants
mais aussi des étudiants en soins
infirmiers des externes des internes en
médecine des soignants retraités sur
tout le territoire et puis de ces
soignants qui se sont formés au cours de
ces derniers mois aux techniques de
réanimation et qui vont prêter main
forte à leurs collègues dans les
services hospitaliers et c'est enfin ce
qu'on appelle les évacuations sanitaires
vous souvenez de ces évacuations
sanitaires qui avaient été réalisés déjà
au printemps dernier c'est lorsqu'on
transfert un patient d'un service de
réanimation d'une région verte un autre
service dans une autre région par avion
par hélicoptère tout cela nécessite
aussi un énorme travail et mobilise
beaucoup de personnel ce sont plus de
120 évacuations sanitaires qui ont déjà
été réalisés des régions les plus en
tension comme auvergne rhône-alpes ou
bourgogne franche comté vers d'autres
territoires comme la nouvelle aquitaine
bretagne ou encore l'île de france je le
disais c'est une logistique lourde c'est
aussi un déplacement pour les malades
qui se retrouvent donc éloigné d'eux
reproche c'est pourquoi nous avons
décidé de prendre en charge les frais de
transport et d'hébergement pour au moins
un accompagnant des patients lorsqu'ils
sont transférés dans le cadre de ces
évacuations sanitaires
par ailleurs nous l'avons déjà dit et
notamment la semaine dernière nous avons
appris davantage sur comment bien
prendre en charge des malades atteints
du coded et nous avons fait d'énormes
progrès en matière de connaissances et
d'organisation et de logistique
notamment à l'hôpital mais pas que
souvenez vous la semaine dernière nous
avons présenté avec des médecins
généralistes comment la prise en charge
s'organisait désormais davantage en
médecine de ville au domicile du patient
les sociétés savantes les collège des
médecins les soignants ont été
massivement consulter des
recommandations ont été arrêtés qui vont
permettre à chaque professionnel de
santé qu'il soit en ville ou à l'hôpital
de disposer de la bonne manière de
soigner et d'accompagner les patients
ça peut aller d'ailleurs jusqu'à
l'équipement en oxygène au domicile des
malades lorsqu'ils ont une forme
symptomatique
mais dont l'état de santé ne justifie
pas une hospitalisation
de la même manière nous avons développé
vous le savez la téléexpertise la
télésanté la télémédecine qui permet
d'accompagner les patients à leur
domicile mais également les soignants
les infirmiers à domicile qui s'occupe
de surveiller leurs malades dans leur
maison nous avons également fait ce
qu'on appelle une vie l'attention de
tout le secteur hospitalier c'est-à-dire
que nous avons amélioré encore les
prises en charge dans les services de
soins critiques dans les services de
soins intensifs de soins continus qui
sont capables d'accueillir désormais
dans leur lit des malades qui autrefois
aller systématiquement en réanimation
n'ont pas des malades qui sont placés en
coma et qui sont qui ont un tube dans
les bronches pour les aider à respirer
mais des malades dont l'état est
instable mais qui je dirais se satisfait
d'une oxygénation c'est-à-dire de
l'arrivée d'oxygène à très fort débit
par voie nasale tout cela nous permet de
vraiment d'augmenter de façon massive
l'ensemble des capacités de prise en
charge et d'accueil des malades dans les
hôpitaux ce qui fait que si nous avons
déjà presque atteint le nombre
d'hospitalisations de la première vague
et bien nous sommes à un niveau
d'admission en réanimation à ce stade
nous l'espérons pour de bon inférieur au
nombre d'hospitalisations en réanimation
observé pendant la première vague et
puis par ailleurs nous avons également
réduit les durée moyenne
d'hospitalisation à l'hôpital comme en
réanimation notamment en nous appuyant
sur les services de rééducation ou sur
les sorties de l'hôpital précoce vers le
domicile où là aussi les patients
peuvent être traités par anti coagulant
corticoïdes et oxygène suivis par leur
médecin traitant et par des infirmiers
libéraux
ce qui permet de diminuer la part de
l'hôpital dans la prise en charge et de
réduire un peu l'impact de la pression
sanitaires sur nos établissements
deuxième volet que vous m'avez demandé
d'aborder monsieur le premier ministre
sur la question des tests antigénique
d'abord rappeler qu'en france nous
réalisons toujours environ deux millions
deux cent mille tests pcr par semaine ce
qui fait que la france reste le pays
d'europe qui testent le plus avec
l'angleterre est avec l'allemagne nous
avons cette innovation formidable que
sont les tests antigénique je rappelle
un écouvillon nage naso pharyngé comme
pour un test pcr classiques et ensuite
au lieu d'envoyer le prélèvement dans un
laboratoire et bien la personne qui
réalise ce prélèvement peut directement
par une petite manip technique
regardez sur un test si vous êtes
positif pour le virus
donc si vous ne l'êtes pas si vous êtes
patients symptomatiques et si vous devez
être positif au test même si vous étiez
d'ailleurs asymptomatiques si votre test
est positif
la fiabilité du test est excellente elle
est un petit peu moins en revanche
lorsque le test est négatif
et si vous êtes symptomatique et que
votre test antigénique et lui négatif
il est possible qu'on vous demande de
faire quand même un test pcr pour
compléter des expérimentations grandeur
nature ont été menées dans tout le pays
depuis plusieurs semaines
rien qu'un exemple la semaine dernière
sur la semaine qui s'est écoulée cent
soixante mille tests antigénique ont été
faites auprès de soignants dans les
ehpad de tout notre pays
ces tests antigénique se déploie aussi
massivement dans les services d'urgences
à l'hôpital quand il faut savoir si un
patient qui a de la fièvre
il faut savoir très rapidement si c'est
le col vide ou non il se déploie
également dans les aéroports dans les
ports et bientôt dans les prochains
jours à partir de la semaine prochaine
il
ceux déployés également dans les
établissements scolaires à destination
du personnel enseignant mais de
l'ensemble d'ailleurs du personnel qui
peut travailler dans les écoles de
manière à permettre de lever toute
suspicion de maladie lorsque quelqu'un
présenterez par exemple des symptômes
alors vous si vous êtes dans la
situation de vous poser la question si
vous pouvez bénéficier d'un test
antigénique et bien c'est très simple si
vous êtes symptomatique
sachez que désormais bon nombre de
pharmaciens d'officine en ville mais
également de médecins libéraux et
d'infirmiers libéraux sont formés et
réalise désormais eux-mêmes des tests
antigénique et donc si vous tombez sur
un professionnel de santé qui a fait ce
choix
eh bien il pourra vous proposer ce
diagnostic par test antigénique rien que
dans la journée d'hier 3000 français ont
été diagnostiqués positifs via des tests
antigénique fait auprès de leurs
professionnels de santé en ville et vous
bénéficierez de la même manière du
contact racing et des mesures de mise à
l'abri
si vous êtes évidemment positif si vous
êtes asymptomatiques deux cas de figure
si vous êtes asymptomatiques mais qu'à
contacter les recommandations de la
haute autorité de santé qui vient
vraiment un très gros travail sont que
vous devez bénéficier d'un test
classique en laboratoire par pcr et si
par contre vous êtes asymptomatiques
mais pas qu'à contacter eh bien
peut-être que vous pourrez être dépistés
par test antigénique chez votre
professionnel de santé je dis peut-être
parce qu'il n'en a pas l'obligation mail
ci il a de la place disponible et qu'il
en fait le choix il pourra vous faire
bénéficier de ce test
par ailleurs un certain nombre de
collectivités mais également
d'entreprises nous ont fait savoir
qu'elles souhaitaient procéder à des
campagnes de dépistage
à partir de ces tests antigénique dans
les prochains jours nous serons amenés à
présenter des protocoles qui permettront
d'accompagner les collectivités et les
entreprises dans la réalisation de ces
dépistages partout où ça fait sens
évidemment sous la responsabilité d'un
professionnel de santé
nous aurons l'occasion d'y revenir la
semaine prochaine enfin sachez que
l'état français a passé une commande
supplémentaire de près de 20 millions de
tests antigénique dans le cadre d'un
appel d'offres européen ce qui permet de
compléter l'offre disponible
sachant que pareil
des pharmaciens les médecins peuvent
acheter eux mêmes des tests auprès des
différents laboratoires agréés donc
voyez cette technique de test se
développe elle ne remplacera pas les
tests pcr qui sont fiables qui sont
efficaces et qui mobilise toute la
filière de biologie de notre pays elle
va venir
implémenter compléter enrichir partout
où c'est nécessaire
notre capacité de dépistage merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre nous
allons faire un point sur le la
situation dans l'éducation nationale et
je demande à monsieur le ministre jean
michel blanquer de bien vouloir il
procéder merci monsieur le premier
ministre pour la pour l'éducation
nationale la crise de la gestion de la
crise qu vide depuis l'apparition en
mars et la conciliation de deux
exigences l'exigence d'abord d'arriver à
ce qui est une continuité des
apprentissages et puis l'exigence est
évidemment de protection sanitaire
c'est cette exigence qui a commandé
l'ensemble des mesures prises depuis le
mois de mars et j'ai eu d'ailleurs
l'occasion en début de semaine indiquées
l'impact des politiques que nous avons
pu mener sur les élèves notamment à
l'école primaire et je voudrais le
rappeler très brièvement parce que nous
ne perdons pas de vue nos priorités dans
cette période à l'école primaire c'est
lire écrire compter
respecter autrui à la sortie de l'école
primaire ce que nous voyons c'est que
les élèves de cp l'an dernier ont un peu
pâti de la période de confinement et
nous avons pu atténuer certains des
inconvénients mais néanmoins ils ont
pâti de ce confinement
les élèves de cm2 pour prendre les deux
classes aux extrémités de l'école
élémentaire eux ont continué les progrès
qu'on constate avec ont constaté l'année
précédente on le voit il ne faut pas
perdre de vue cet enjeu qui est majeure
et si je regarde les résultats de la
france sur cette question nous
réussissons à traverser l'épidémie en
assurant la continuité des
apprentissages
bien sûr ça reste l'enjeu depuis cette
rentrée et cela reste l'enjeu sur le
plan sanitaire dans le cadre du
protocole sanitaire qui a été définie au
mois de juillet et prévoient vous le
savez différentes mesures en fonction
des situations épidémiologiques possible
donc nous avons un cadre de mesures dans
lesquelles nous pour lesquelles nous
pouvons faire évoluer les curseurs et
c'est ce qui s'est passé
depuis le 1er septembre le protocole
s'est appliqué du 1er septembre au 16
octobre et nous a permis le retour en
classe de pratiquement tous les élèves à
l'école au collège et au lycée
mais insiste encore sur ce point c'est
une victoire une victoire d'ailleurs de
l'ensemble des professeurs et des
personnels de l'éducation nationale et
des collectivités locales puisque tous
les pays n'ont pas pu faire cela et
aujourd'hui ce retour à l'école de tous
les enfants est un objectif fondamental
la deuxième vague qui a d'ailleurs été
accentuée s'agissant des enfants et des
adolescents par les vacances d'automne
nous a conduits à faire évoluer nos
curseur et c'est donc la situation dans
laquelle nous sommes depuis maintenant
une semaine et demie nous avons donc en
d'autres termes durs si le protocole ces
nouvelles mesures applicables depuis le
2 novembre consistent surtout à la
limitation des brassages les brassages
des élèves
la généralisation du port du masque pour
tous les élèves dès le cp en sachant que
tous les personnels le portait depuis la
rentrée mais aussi l'aération la
désinfection plus fréquente des locaux
autant de mesures qui d'ailleurs souvent
ce sont prises avec les collectivités
locales dont c'est la compétence
s'agissant des bâtiments nous avons
laissé aux écoles et aux établissements
quelques jours pour s'adapter au retour
des vacances scolaires et certains
établissements en plus de difficultés
que d'autres parce que chaque école
chaque collège chaque lycée est un cas
différent
rappelons qu'il ya plus de soixante
mille établissements scolaires et écoles
en france dans les lycées la limitation
du brassage des élèves est plus complexe
à organiser
d'une part du fait de la taille des
établissements est d'une part et d'autre
part du fait des déplacements plus
nombreux des élèves la structure du
groupe classe et beaucoup moins établi
qu'en primaire au collège et en plus
l'âge des élèves et leur mode de vie
rendent cette population d'élèves plus
sensibles aux risques sanitaires
c'est pourquoi nous avons prévu depuis
la semaine dernière une souplesse pour
les lycées de façon à ce que dans un
cadre national bien défini ils puissent
avoir des adaptations locales
correspondant à leur réalité
nous avons établi cela en lien notamment
avec les chefs d'établissements les
partenaires sociaux et ce cadrage
précise que dans la mesure où un lycée
peut
encore le faire c'est le cas par exemple
de deux lycées où il ya peu d'élèves est
bien bien sûr la présence à 100 % des
élèves reste souhaitable mais dès lors
qu'il n'est pas possible pour un
établissement d'assurer les conditions
sanitaires requises lorsque tous les
élèves sont présents et bien des
solutions hybrides sont proposés j'ai
toutefois demandé que au minimum 50% du
temps scolaire de l'élève se déroule
dans le lycée d'ici à la fin de l'année
civile afin de garantir le maintien d'un
lien fort avec la classe
j'ai demandé aussi à ce que chaque
lycées établissent avec le soutien le
suivi de chaque rectorat un plan précis
de continuité pédagogique qui détaille
les modalités d enseignement et
notamment de l'enseignement à distance
pour l'élève avec les collectivités
locales
nous avons travaillé tout au long des
derniers mois aussi bien pour
l'acquisition de matériel informatique
que pour l'équipement des établissements
eux mêmes
et puis il ya eu des sessions de
formation des professeurs toutes ces
actions continuent encore aujourd'hui au
cours des prochaines semaines
les académies des rectorats donc ont mis
en place des cellules de continuité
pédagogique pour accompagner et suivre
la bonne mise en place de ces plans la
mise en oeuvre de l'enseignement à
distance demande une forte mobilisation
des chefs d'établissement et des
professeurs
je veux remercier tous ceux qui
contribuent aujourd'hui à cette
continuité pédagogique
nous allons par ailleurs des déployé
plus de jeunes du service civique plus
d'assistants d'éducation et plus de
professeurs remplaçants dans le premier
degré comme dans le second degré chaque
fois que cela sera nécessaire
je voudrais enfin faire référence à la
politique de tests dont le ministre
olivier ferrand vient de nous parler
parce que en effet dans le cadre du
travail accompli entre ministères de la
santé et le ministère de l'éducation
nationale
il y aura plus de dépistage des
personnels travaillant dans nos écoles
et dans nos établissements scolaires
dans les prochaines heures une
instruction interministérielle se
renvoyaient à toutes les académies et à
toutes les agences régionales de santé
elle rappelle que nos personnels sont
prioritaires pour l'accès aux tests pcr
permet aussi le déploiement de près d'un
million deux cent mille tests
antigénique qui seront mis à disposition
des établissements scolaires
avec des personnels de santé venus d
administration de santé comme de
l'éducation nationale certaines zones
plus exposés au virus seront
prioritaires et l'instruction précise
toutes les modalités de déploiement de
ces tests je voudrais à nouveau
remercier tous nos personnels mais aussi
les parents d'élèves pour la période
difficile que nous traversons
notre critère c'est toujours l'élève lui
permettre d'aller à l'école d'aller au
collège et d'aller autant que possible
au lycée de bénéficier d'une continuité
pédagogique donc continuer à accomplir
nos deux objectifs fondamentaux qui sont
de hausser le niveau général du pays et
d'assurer la lutte contre les inégalités
sociales
or nous savons qu'elles peuvent être
aggravées par un confinement des élèves
nous pouvons avoir à la fois de la
cohérence et de la cohésion dans
l'ensemble des mesures qui sont prises
merci donc à tous ceux qui y contribuent
merci monsieur le premier ministre
merci beaucoup monsieur mise éducation
nationale pour évoquer la mise en place
du confinement dans les milieux
professionnels et notamment la question
du télétravail
j'invite madame elisabeth bornes
ministre en charge du sujet à s'exprimer
devant vous merci monsieur le premier
ministre
bonsoir à toutes et à tous le premier
ministre l'a rappelé la situation que
nous vivons en ce moment n'est pas la
même qu'au printemps dernier
en mars nous avions demandé aux français
de rester chez eux et de faire ce qu'ils
pouvaient en télétravail et de fait
notre économie s'était largement arrêté
nous voulons cette fois que l'activité
économique se poursuive en matière de
télétravail je le rappelle la règle qui
s'applique désormais est la suivante
ce dont les tâches peuvent être
entièrement réalisés à distance doivent
télétravail et cinq jours sur cinq ce
qui ne peuvent aller travailler que
partiellement ou qui sont dans
l'impossibilité de le faire peuvent
continuer à se rendre sur leur lieu de
travail en toute sécurité grâce au
protocole sanitaire en entreprise qui
garantit leur protection
cela fait maintenant deux semaines que
ces règles sont entrées en vigueur après
une première semaine test pour laisser
le temps aux employeurs et aux salariés
de s'organiser
nous avons mené une enquête auprès de
2000 français du 4 au 8 novembre dernier
pour voir si les règles étaient bien
appliquée l'enquète le montre la très
grande majorité des employeurs et des
salariés jouent le jeu et je les en
remercie première confirmation de cette
enquête tous les français ne peuvent pas
télétravail et un tiers des actifs peu
télétravail est facilement mais plus
d'un tiers des français ont un métier
qui n'est pas du tout et les
travaillable deuxième enseignement l'
enquête montre qu'une majorité de ceux
qui peuvent télétravail et l'ont fait et
ils ont fait davantage que la semaine
précédente
ainsi 45 % des salariés du privé qui ont
travaillé la semaine dernière ont fait
du télétravail dont 23% cinq jours sur
cinq
c'est un bon score quand on sait que
tous les salariés ne peuvent pas
télétravail et autres points positifs ce
qui ce qui télétravaillent le font
davantage en moyenne 3 7 jours contre
2.7 la semaine d'avant
en ce qui concerne le télétravail dans
le secteur public
il progresse également près de 40% des
agents de l'état hors éducation
nationale police et gendarmerie sont
aujourd'hui en télétravail soit près de
12 points de plus que la semaine
précédente
et n'oublions pas comme l'a rappelé
amélie de montchalin la ministre de la
fonction publique que nous voulons aussi
maintenir les services publics ouverts
contrairement aux premiers confinement
troisième enseignement le télétravail
cinq jours sur 5 représente un véritable
effort pour les salariés qui souffrent
parfois d'isolement en effet près de six
français sur dix qui ont télétravail est
à 100% préféré venir sur leur lieu de
travail au moins un jour par semaine
quatre salariés sur dix qui ont
télétravail et la semaine dernière
disent se sentir isolé pour leur venir
en aide et accompagne et tous ceux qui
ne bénéficient pas de dispositif de
soutien psychologique
dans leur entreprise nous avons lancé
une ligne d'écouté et de conseil dont le
numéro s'affiche à l'écran
j'ai conscience que nous demandons un
effort très important aux employeurs et
aux salariés mais il est indispensable
dans la lutte contre le virus
je tiens à les remercier une nouvelle
fois pour leur mobilisation
mais l' enquête ne montre il y a encore
des marges de progrès pour que plus
d'actifs télétravail
j'appelle donc tous les employeurs et
les salariés à poursuivre leurs efforts
chaque jour chaque heure télétravail est
content
concernant la situation du marché du
travail et des demandeurs d'emploi je le
redis le confinement actuelle n'est pas
le même au printemps dernier nous avons
fait le choix de maintenir l'activité
économique de notre pays et de nombreux
secteurs continuent à tourner et avoir
ce qui est une bonne nouvelle
une activité soutenue il existe des
opportunités d'emploi malgré la période
on a compté trois cent quarante mille
créations d'emplois au troisième
trimestre 2020 elles seront encore
dynamisée par le plan de relance
le service public de l'emploi continue à
fonctionner avec le maintien de
l'accueil dans les agences de pôle
emploi et les missions locales les
équipes sont mobilisées pour accompagner
les demandeurs d'emploi il y à des
métiers en tension des métiers porteurs
il y à des offres d'emploi non pourvues
il ya aussi des formations pour
permettre aux demandeurs d'emploi
d'aller vers des solutions durables
notre priorité reste l'emploi nous avons
conscience que la situation est
difficile pour deux pour un grand nombre
de demandeurs d'emploi et nous devons
plus que jamais rassurer et protéger
comme l'a annoncé le premier ministre
nous allons donc prolongé de la durée du
confinement les droits à l'assurance
chômage pour les chômeurs arrivant en
fin de droit par exemple un demandeur
d'emploi dont les droits auraient dû
s'éteindre fin novembre continuera à
toucher son allocation chômage au mois
de décembre
nous laissons également un délai
supplémentaire pour s'inscrire à pôle
emploi
un demandeur d'emploi qui doit réunir
les pièces pour s'inscrire bénéficiera
d'un délai supplémentaire
rassembler tous les justificatifs
nécessaires ce qui peut être plus
difficile dans la période de confinement
enfin nous allongeons la période de
référence pour bénéficier d'une
allocation chômage alors qu'aujourd'hui
un demandeur d'emploi doit avoir
travaillé travaillé au moins quatre mois
sur une période de 27 mois ces 27 mois
seront prolongés de la durée du
confinement
nous avons entendu les inquiétudes des
demandeurs d'emploi et plus largement
des partenaires sociaux et des
associations de lutte contre la pauvreté
soyez assurés que nous sommes déterminés
à y répondre
je remercie merci beaucoup madame la
ministre j'ai évoqué les sujets
essentiels de l'accompagnement
économique des secteurs en difficulté
notamment de ceux qui sont impactés par
les mesures de sécurité sanitaire que
nous prenons j'invite le ministre en
charge l'économie des finances et de la
relance bruno le maire à vous faire un
point à ce jour merci monsieur le
premier ministre a comme l'indiqué le
premier ministre les commerçants sont au
coeur de nos préoccupations
quand des préoccupations de chacun
d'entre nous je sais que nombre de
commerçants ont hâte de rouvrir le plus
rapidement possible que beaucoup ont
constitué des stocks en vue des fêtes de
noël et des fêtes de fin d'année souvent
ils doivent payer ses stocks au moment
même où ils sont fermées et où ils n'ont
pas de trésorerie disponible par
ailleurs beaucoup d'entre eux je pense
ou libraire
je pense au bijoutier au magasin de
jouets font près de la moitié de leur
chiffre d'affaires dans les deux
derniers mois de l'année
la réouverture est donc vital pour eux
et nous le savons je crois que le
calendrier que vient de fixer le premier
ministre est de ce point de vue un motif
d'espoir pour les commerçants français
mais la meilleure façon de réussir cette
ouverture c'est que chacun respecte des
règles sanitaires dans les jours à venir
comme cela a été rappelé depuis
plusieurs minutes
en attendant je tiens à vous confirmer
que toutes les mesures économiques
massive que nous avons annoncées avec le
premier ministre le président de la
république au début du mois et que nous
avons mises en place pour les
commerçants continueront de s'appliquer
dans les quinze jours qui viennent et je
veux les rappeler pour que chacun voit
bien à quoi il a droit concrètement les
commerçants qui sont fermées
administrativement tous sans exception
ont le droit à une aide qui peut aller
jusqu'à dix mille euros pour le fonds de
solidarité
ils ont droit à l'activité partielle à
l'exonération de charges sociales et au
report du remboursement des prêts
garantis par l'état
nous veillerons bien entendu à la bonne
exécution de ces dispositifs et je
veillerai personnellement avec la
direction générale des finances
publiques à ce que chaque commerçant
fermés puissent déclarer le chiffre
d'affaires qu'il a perdue d'ici le tout
début du mois de décembre afin de
pouvoir bénéficier de cette aide du
fonds de solidarité dans les premiers
jours du mois de décembre
j'insiste là dessus parce que je vois
beaucoup de commerçants qui me dise où
sont les aides quand viennent tel il
faut que le mois de novembre c'est cool
mais ensuite dans les tout premiers
jours du mois de décembre
ils pourront avoir accès à ce fonds de
solidarité dont je rappelle qu'il
accumule cumulables avec les revenus du
retrait commande le click and collect
qui peut constituer un appoint financier
pour certains nous savons également que
la question des loyers reste la question
majeure pour nine mance majorité de
commerçants à la demande du président de
la république et du premier ministre
je vous annonce que nous mettrons en
place un dispositif simple massif est
nouveau pour les loyers des commerçants
ce dispositif résulte des consultations
que j'ai eu depuis plusieurs jours avec
l'ensemble des associations et des
fédérations représentatives des
bailleurs et des commerçants en accord
avec toutes ces associations et toutes
ces fédérations sans exception nous
mettrons en place dans le budget 2021
un crédit d'impôt de 50% du montant de
loyer abandonné pour tous les bailleurs
qui renonce au loyer du mois de novembre
pour toutes les entreprises qui ont
jusqu'à 250 salariés et qui sont ferme
et j'invite à nouveau par conséquent
tous les bailleurs qui ont signé cet
accord à renoncer à leur loyer du mois
de novembre pour tous les commerces
jusqu'à 250 salariés qui sont fermés un
petit bailleur par exemple qui pour
compléter sa retraite dispose d'un loyer
de 600 euros touchera 300 euros de
crédit d'impôt est locataire lui du coup
n'aura pas à payer son loyer du mois de
novembre cela l'aidera à passer cette
période difficile
un bailleur plus importante et
renoncerait un loyer de 5000 euros
touchera un crédit d'impôt de 2500 euros
nous avons voulu aussi traiter des
entreprises plus importantes
les entreprises de taille intermédiaire
parce qu'il ya des galeries marchandes
et galeries commerciales qui sont
concernés et qui sont elles aussi
menacées et nous n'avons voulu laisser
personne de côté
par conséquent pour les entreprises de
250 et jusqu'à 5000 salariés
ce dispositif s'appliquera également
mais dans la limite des deux tiers du
montant des loyers
cela signifie qu'un bailleur qui renonce
aux loyers par exemple d'une grande
surface commerciale pour un loyer de
12000 euros mensuels aura un crédit
d'impôt d'un tiers soit de 4000 euros
je tiens sincèrement à remercier
l'ensemble des associations et
fédérations de bailleurs car c'est la
première fois que nous trouverons un
accord collectif sur mesure de cette
importance qui traduit le sens des
responsabilités et l'esprit de
solidarité sans lequel nous ne pourrons
pas participer pleinement à la relance
notre activité économique pour surmonter
la crise actuelle
enfin comme l'a indiqué le premier
ministre devons mettre à profit les
jours qui viennent pour travailler avec
olivier ferrand et les abeilles bornes
dans deux directions
la première c'est l'application des
nouvelles règles sanitaires qui
s'appliqueront au moment de la
réouverture des commerces et quand cette
réouverture sera possible nous pouvons
travailler par exemple
sur le renforcement de la jauge ou
éventuellement pour certains commerces
cela serait pertinent sur la possibilité
de prise de rendez vous je souhaite
également sa deuxième direction à
laquelle nous voulons travailler engager
dès maintenant une nouvelle consultation
avec tous les secteurs dans lesquels le
port du masque n'est pas possible comme
la restauration ou les salles de sport
et où donc par conséquent les
difficultés sont encore plus grande et
où ces difficultés s'inscrivait la
s'étend le long terme
je crois que pour ces secteurs aussi
nous devons donner de la visibilité sur
les points de sortie et préparer un
avenir que nous souhaitons meilleur à
tous merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre mes chers
concitoyens je veux vous dire combien je
ressens les difficultés du pays je
mesure les souffrances et parfois le
désespoir de beaucoup d'entre vous
adopter des mesures difficiles constitue
évidemment un crève coeur mais il est de
ma responsabilité de le faire mon devoir
est de vous protéger contre le virus et
ses ravages contre le terrorisme contre
le chômage
créé par la crise sanitaire le
gouvernement comme moi même sommes
mobilisés 24 heures sur 24 et 7 jours
sur 7
sous l'autorité du président de la
république nous avons fait le choix
d'accompagner massivement ceux qui
souffrent ceux qui sont fragiles et
vulnérables ceux qui font l'objet des
mesures administratives rendu nécessaire
pour lutter contre la propagation de
l'épidémie et nous continuerons d'agir
dans ce sens le propre de cette crise
c'est qu'elle nous donne à toutes et à
tous le moyen d'être un acteur de la
lutte contre l'épidémie
l'occasion d'exprimer notre solidarité
notre sens des responsabilités car nul
ne peut se croire invincible ou épargné
nous constatons des évolutions positives
premiers effets des mesures prises ces
évolutions ne justifierait pas un
durcissement des mesures mais elles sont
trop fragiles est trop récente pour
autoriser le moindre relâchement
plus que jamais je vous invite à
respecter rigoureusement les règles du
confinement à ne sortir de chez vous que
lorsque c'est strictement nécessaire est
autorisé à télétravailler au maximum à
redoubler de prudence si vous êtes
particulièrement vulnérables au virus a
observé des gestes barrières le port du
masque y compris chez vous à aérer ou
ventilés au maximum les espaces cloud à
télécharger l'application tous antico
vide
je n'ignore rien des polémiques et des
contestations mais ne nous y trompons
pas l'ennemi ce n'est pas l'état ni le
gouvernement c'est le virus le seul
combat qui m'obsède
c'est celui de notre sécurité la seule
courbe qui m'intéresse c'est celle des
malades admis à l'hôpital ou en
réanimation
grâce à nos efforts collectifs grâce aux
perspectives qu'ouvre l'arrivée de
vaccins
je suis sûr que nous surmonterons cette
épreuve douloureuse et inédite grâce à
notre mobilisation immédiate
j'espère que nous pourrons passer des
fêtes de fin d'année dans la sérénité
je me tiens avec les ministres à votre
disposition pour répondre à vos
questions
monsieur le premier ministre bonsoir
madame messieurs les ministres camille
collin pour tf1 et lci pour bien
comprendre vos propos le coup finement
va-t-il se poursuivre après le 1er
décembre et jusqu'aux vacances de noël
avec le même système d'attestation de
dérogation est question complémentaire
pourquoi ne pas
ne pas envisager progressivement un
passage un confinement territorialisée
des mesures plus dures dans les régions
les plus touchées comme celle de
dauvergne ronald est moins dure plus
souple dans d'autres régions
merci bien autre question bonjour tir et
kurt et france 2 vous avez évoqué un
certain nombre de réouverture à partir
du 1er décembre
cela concernera quel commerce quelle
boutique est ce que nous pourrons faire
nos vacances nos courses de noël dans
toutes les boutiques et puis deuxième
question est ce qu'on peut commencer à
prendre nos billets de train pour les
vacances et pour les fêtes de noël
on va peut-être prendre une troisième
question et après on fait comme
d'habitude j'aurais des ministres
bonjour monsieur le premier ministre
liliane delmas le courrier du parlement
vous aviez annoncé précédemment que les
jauges pour les obsèques était de 25
personnes et pour les mariages de six
personnes
sans polémiquer on aurait attendu des
chiffres inverse
je voulais savoir simplement s'il est
même le les mêmes montants si je puis
dire était heureux enfin continuer de la
même façon pour les obsèques et pour le
mariage bien alors je commence ma
première question si vous voulez bien
donc le 1er décembre
j'ai indiqué que compte tenu des
éléments dont nous disposons aujourd'hui
les règles applicables au confinement
continuerait à s'appliquer c'est à dire
madame celle que vous avez dit est que
si les données sanitaires continuent à
évoluer dans le sens de ce que nous
observons aujourd'hui avec la même
dynamique
nous pourrions rouvrir alors quel
commerce se tiendra la deuxième question
est bien aujourd'hui sont ne sont
ouverts que les commerces dits de
première nécessité ou les rayons
correspondants dans les grandes surfaces
bien ce serait le reste des commerces
qui seraient concernés j'insiste auprès
de vous faut-il que les données
sanitaires le permettent
et faut-il aussi sous la houlette des
ministres que les protocoles qui sont en
cours de discussions de concertations
avec les professionnels concernés
aboutissent dans de bonnes conditions
il m'a été demandé si on pourrait passer
à un confinement plus territorialisée
sous le contrôle du ministre de la santé
je pense que à l'échéance du 1er
décembre puisque telle était la question
le moment ne sera pas vraisemblablement
encore venu d'envisager cette étape
s'agissant des billets de train je pense
qu'il est pardonnez moi et je vais être
très honnête avec vous un peu tôt pour
répondre à cette question nous nous
sommes fait le gouvernement s'est
renseigné auprès notamment de la sncf
pour savoir à partir de quand il serait
trop tard en sens inverse donc nous
avons encore un peu de temps devant nous
mais très vite en fonction là aussi des
données sanitaires nous pourrons
apporter une réponse claire à cette
question pour que les français
évidemment puisque je sens bien que tel
était l'objet de votre demande puisse
s'organiser dans des délais raisonnables
pour procéder à ces réservations et jeu
je ne vois pas madame de motif à ce
stade pour modifier
pas plus d'ailleurs ces règles que
d'autres roms sur les sujets que vous
avez évoquées pour tf1 ma première
question porte sur les conditions de la
réouverture des commerces et se fait à
partir du 1er décembre pourquoi vouloir
mettre en place un protocole renforcé en
quelque sorte ne pas garder le protocole
qui existait au moment du des
confirmands pénaliser les plus petits
commerces
mon autre question porte sur la prise en
charge des patients qu'aux vide
vous parliez du transfert de patients
d'une région à l'autre mais pourquoi ne
pas décider de mettre en place des
structures mobiles ou des hôpitaux de
campagne dans les autres qui sont les
plus touchés par le virus
très clair merci bonjour me marot de la
fff je me permet de reposer la question
de ma consoeur de tf1 chemical 1 est ce
que au 1er décembre
si la tendance actuelle se confirmait
avec les prémices d'un frémissement
positif
il faudra une attestation pour circuler
oui oui oui
alexis cuvillier de bfmtv bonsoir
monsieur le premier ministre sur la
question des déplacements après le 1er
décembre
est-ce que même si le confinement est
maintenu dans des règles assez strictes
il y aura des possibilités d'aller voir
sa famille et ses proches dans d'autres
régions ou de prendre le train pour
s'éloigner de son lieu de vie et je
pense notamment bien sûr au moment des
fêtes de fin d'année une autre question
sur l'objectif de 5000 cas par jour qui
avait été évoquée par le président de la
république au moment de son allocution
annonçant leur confinement est ce que
cet objectif vous semble atteignable à
moyen terme et enfin une question peut
être un peu plus politique beaucoup de
critiques ces derniers jours dans
l'opposition sur le fonctionnement du
conseil de défense vous les avez
probablement entendu certains
parlementaires notamment où
ou chefs de l'opposition reproche de ne
pas être assez associés à la prise de
décision et dénonce une forme d'opacité
je voudrais avoir votre réponse là
dessus merci beaucoup dernière question
de trois bonjour monsieur le premier
ministre jean-yves au dos pour europe 1
le 6 mai dernier devant le sénat lors de
votre audition en tant que coordinateur
du déconfinement vous avez déclaré dans
le cadre de la sortie de confinement que
j'ai préparé j'ai proposé que soient
prêts un plan éventuel de confinement
parce que ça se prépare à quoi
faisiez-vous précisément référence y
avait-il des bus mais réellement un
projet de re confinement et sinon
pourquoi l'avoir dit devant le sénat
merci très bien je vais commencer par
cette question monsieur puisque je
confirme avoir tenu ces propos en effet
dans la mission qui était la mienne à
l'époque confié par edouard si libre de
préparer le déconfinement j'ai estimé
nécessaire à l'instar d'ailleurs de ce
que font tous les tous les pays qui nous
entourent de prévoir l'hypothèse où ce
déconfinement oise de confinement
succédera une aggravation ou une reprise
épidémique qui comment dire a toujours
été dans le paysage d'abord je rappelle
à tout le monde que lorsqu'on regarde
l'histoire des grandes épidémies
je pense en particulier à la grippe
espagnole d'il ya cent ans il y avait eu
deux vagues épidémiques l'organisation
mondiale de la santé
dès le départ faisait allusion à la
possibilité de plusieurs vagues
épidémiques donc je veux dire c'est une
constante dans l'histoire des pandémies
donc je n'ai rien fait d'autre que
rappeler cette donnée est préconisé
effectivement que cette hypothèse se
produit ça soit préparé je vous
observerez d'ailleurs qu'à l'époque
puisque vous y faites allusion je
m'étais exprimé devant la commission
denquête constitué par le sénat pendant
plus d'une heure et n'avait été retenu
que quasiment cette intervention où
j'évoquais une possibilité de re
confinement donc
cette hypothèse existe elle a toujours
été intégré à gestion des épidémies et
la france comme les autres et à se
préparer
je vous rappelle qu'à toutes et à tous
que ce qui n'a pas était prévu c'est la
violence de la reprise épidémique qui
est content qui a été constatée dans
tous les pays d'europe c'est à dire que
nous avions une évolution des cas qui
étaient plutôt linéaire et tout d'un
coup ça s'est envolée sans doute sans
doute nous disent les scientifiques sous
l'effet de facteurs climatiques sans
qu'ils en soient complètement certain
mais vous l'avez observé tous les pays
en europe ont constaté ce phénomène qui
a obligé les uns et les autres à prendre
des mesures de la nature d'ailleurs de
celles que nous avons adopté donc
l'attestation j'ai répondu que la
question allait voir sa famille et
déplacements reprend rigoureusement me
semble-t-il la même question à laquelle
j'ai répondu sur les billets de train il
y a ensuite donc une question sur les
protocoles sur le commerce et sur le
nombre de cas par jour peut-être que le
minsanté s'il veut bien pas s'approcher
du micro pour y répondre puisque ce sont
plutôt des questions sanitaires et je
vais répondre moi même sur la question
du conseil de défense kim tae kim a été
posée effectivement et que et que
j'entends bon il me semble que en
réalité les choses sont relativement
simples
nous sommes dans une crise sanitaire
extrêmement grave
sa gestion dans l' équilibre
institutionnel de notre pays dans le
cadre des lois de la république et de la
séparation des pouvoirs relève du
pouvoir exécutif ce qui est inévitable
compte tenu des décisions qu'il ya lieu
de prendre parfois de la rapidité avec
laquelle doivent être prises
le parlement étant plutôt dans un rôle
de contrôle et le gouvernement de compte
rendu de son action devant lui
donc ça c'est le premier élément le
deuxième élément c'est que me
semble-t-il
il appartient aux pouvoirs exécutifs de
décider des voies et moyens dans
lesquelles il gère cette crise
depuis le début effectivement le
président de la république a souhaité
qu' on va dire l'instance majeur de
décision soit une instance qui
existaient bien avant la crise que vides
qui s'appelle effectivement le conseil
de défense et de sécurité nationale
c'est un mode de gouvernance qui est
parfaitement justifiée simplement ce que
je veux vous dire c'est que évidemment
l'ensemble de l'appareil gouvernemental
prépare les décisions du conseil de
défense exécute ensuite les décisions du
conseil de défense donc là où je ne je
ne comprends pas bien la critique dont
je ne la comprends pas du tout c'est
l'idée que ce serait un pouvoir
personnel avec une opacité pas du tout
c'est c'est vrai que c'est un conseil
ramassés autour du chef de l'état mais
encore une fois le travail
gouvernemental devrait d administration
aussi que je salue ce fait tant en amont
qu'en aval du conseil de défense et donc
encore une fois il n'y a rien qui me
paraît contrevenir à la séparation des
pouvoirs et au rôle normal dévolu tantôt
pouvoir législatif que pouvoir exécutif
monsieur misa santé quatre questions qui
relevait je crois du chant ou trois
questions qui ont fait du champ
sanitaire d'abord l'objectif du nombre
de capes un jour alors en règle il n'y a
pas un objectif premier ministre l'a dit
il ya plusieurs objectifs
l'objectif central s'est retrouvé la
maîtrise de l'épidémie
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire revenir à
un niveau de contamination par jour qui
nous permettent d'assurer le traçage de
toutes les chaînes de contamination pour
éviter qu'un nouveau l'épidémie ne
reparte et donc il nous faut déterminer
quel est le bon niveau de contamination
au quotidien qui nous permettent de
faire face
est ce que ces 5000 est ce que ces 10000
donc nous organisons l'assurance maladie
les agences régionales de santé pour
être capable de mobiliser un maximum de
professionnels pour reprendre le fil des
chaînes de contamination et quand nous
aurons été en mesure de reprendre le fil
des chaînes de contamination et bien
alors nous serons que nous avons repris
le contrôle de l'épidème sur l'épidémie
en général de le deuxième indicateur
c'est la pression sanitaires c'est à
dire à quel moment
est-ce que nous retrouvons avec
évidemment des animations qui seront
quand même sujette attention mais à quel
moment est ce que nous arrêtons de
déprogrammer des soins nous sommes
capables d'accueillir à la fois les
malades du coded et les malades qui
n'ont pas alcôves id parce que ce sera
le reflet d'une baisse de la pression
sanitaires et donc ça veut dire qu'il y
aura moins de gens qui font des formes
peu graves et donc moins de conséquences
sanitaires pour la population
deuxième question c'est est pourquoi
est-ce qu'on fait des évacuations
sanitaires au lieu de mettre des
hôpitaux de campagne
alors d'abord il ya des hôpitaux de
campagne ou des modifications des
hôpitaux existants
vous avez l'hôpital militaire qui
étaient déployés par la ministre des
armées
florence parly en polynésie française
pourquoi en polynésie française parce
que les évacuations sanitaires en
polynésie c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
auprès des pays voisins limitrophes et
donc il faut augmenter sur place les
capacités de prise en charge
hospitalière
et puis vous avez l'exemple toulousain
par exemple qui a mis en place un
système innovant pour pouvoir accueillir
davantage de malades
je ne compte plus le nombre d'hôpitaux
que nous avons visités avec le premier
ministre où on a développé des systèmes
d'urgence d'admission d'urgence
supplémentaire puisque le développement
des lits de réanimation mais au fond
deux points d'abord lorsque vous êtes
arrivé à saturation de tout le personnel
de santé disponibles dans un hôpital
et bien vous allez mettre à contribution
davantage des hôpitaux dans lesquelles
il reste de la place disponible
plutôt que de transporter tout le
personnel de l'hôpital qui est moins
sujet à pression vers les hôpitaux les
plus sujets à pression et ensuite il
faut comprendre que ces évacuations
sanitaires
elles n'ont pas exactement le même
aspect que pendant la première vague au
printemps dernier au printemps dernier
c'était des évacuations à la même
souvenez vous aucune équipe et des tgv
pour pouvoir y mettre des dizaines de
patients pour évacuer en catastrophes si
je puis dire et ça c'est toujours
heureusement bien déroulé des patients
des hôpitaux du grand-est vers d'autres
régions
cette fois ci nous faisons des presque
des évacuations sanitaires par
anticipation dire que quand la pression
sanitaire augmente dans un territoire et
qu'avec les modélisations on sait qu'il
va y avoir davantage de patients jour
après jour et bien dans l'anticipation
on transfère certains patients
transférables de ces hôpitaux vers des
endroits où il ya davantage de places
qui sont disponibles donc c'est le tout
sur les règles sanitaires dans les
petits commerces nous travaillons avec
brune
mais nous avons déjà reçus à bercy les
organisations patronales et nous
continuerons de travailler avec
l'ensemble des acteurs
ce qui se dessine à l'étranger notamment
là où des règles ont été mises en
vigueur je pense à l'allemagne notamment
ce qui peut y avoir ou un système de
jauge
c'est à dire un maximum de clients par
mètre carré ou plutôt un certain nombre
de mètres carrés par client ou un
système de prise de rendez vous selon
les types de commerces ou les deux et
c'est sur ce don bruno le maire parlait
tout à l'heure et que nous devons
continuer de travailler dans les jours
qui viennent de manière à ce que tout
soit parfaitement prêt concerté et
partagé au moment où la question se
posera en pratique puis à une question
tout à l'heure si tu me permettent sur
les mariages et les enterrements savez
pendant la première vague
il ya des familles qui n'ont pas pu
enterrer leurs morts alors quand vous
dites on ne s'attendait à l inverse
c'est-à-dire avoir plus de monde aux
enterrements possible plus de monde aux
mariages des enterrements
je ne suis pas certain que je suis même
pas du tout certains et beaucoup de
familles qui n'ont même pas pu se réunir
à quelques-uns autour de leur défunte
personnes pour pouvoir communier
ensemble est en tout cas rendre un
dernier hommage donc il nous a semblé au
contraire aux importants fondamentale
même d'accorder une forme de dérogation
à cette situation par ailleurs les
mariages qui sont des événements heureux
sont hélas des occasions de se réunir de
partager un repas un apéritif ensemble
et parfois même de prolonger la soirée
et la nuit jusque très tard
je parle des invités et vous avez là us
vous avez lu il a un certain nombre de
contaminations qui ont été observées
tout au long de l'été et donc il était
nécessaire au contraire d'avoir des
règles extrêmement strictes
merci beaucoup donc pour revenir à une
question qui m'a été posée je vais très
clair le 1er décembre les règles de
déplacement
l'attestation vrai at war ne changeront
pas par rapport à la situation actuelle
et nous allons tout faire
s'agissant des déplacements en train ou
pas pour les vacances de noël de au fur
et à mesure de l'évolution sanitaire
précise et ça aux français dans des
délais qui leur permettront de
s'organiser
c'est à dire je l'espère d'ici la fin du
mois de
va d'accord donc à ce jour la seule
chose pour être très pédagogique qui
pourrait changer si les conditions
sanitaires se confirme
si les protocoles sanitaires aboutissent
c'est que les commerces que nous avons
fermé pendant le confinement pourrait
rouvrir
allez je pas encore deux questions
durant ce thème pour vous serez bien la
première monsieur le premier ministre
l'épidémie alors d'accord
l'épidémie progresse dans certains
territoires d'outre-mer particulièrement
polynésie où le centre hospitalier
arrive je voudrais savoir ce qu'il est
envisagé des mesures de durcissement
dans certains territoires d'outre-mer
voire de leur confinement notamment
polynésie merci madame je lance le
premier ministre dans la madame la
ministre monsieur les ministres tardif
pour ses news canal+ je peux parler
d'une lueur d'espoir il ya des vaccins
qui arrive en phase iii des essais
cliniques est ce que vous avez prévu un
plan une stratégie si oui quel est il qu
elle est l des vaccins arrivent donc
dans leur dernière phase en chine en
allemagne au royaume uni aux états unis
en russie il y a un grand absent c'est
la france
sanofi pasteur vous avez à financer la
recherche à plus d'un demi milliard
d'euros comment expliquez vous cette
absence et vous donc des explications
mettez-vous la pression sur sur ces
laboratoires français merci beaucoup je
me la santé
alors mes premières amours
d'abord sur l'outre-mer j'ai parlé
justement par de la polynésie française
pour dire tous les efforts que nous
faisons pour leur venir en aide
pour accueillir des malades notamment
des malades en situation grave nous
travaillons avec le ministre de
l'outre-mer sébastien lecornu travail
évidemment avec l'ensemble de la
représentation de polynésie française
pour ajuster avec eux les mesures les
plus les plus adaptés et donc il ya des
communications communication qui sera
faite aussi prochainement sur sur ce
point particulier sur les vaccins je ne
sais pas ce que vous entendez par mettre
la pression sur laboratoire un
laboratoire c'est avant tout ce sont
avant tout des chercheurs qui
travaillent pour identifier un vaccin
il n'y a pas en l'occurrence de de
primauté nationale dans la capacité
qu'un laboratoire de développer un
vaccin
donc je ne crois pas qu'il faille
comparer en tout cas certainement pas
par ordre de pays pour savoir qui étant
en avance et qu'il n'est pas nous
l'avons dit à la fois que c'est une ce
serait une excellente nouvelle si un
vaccin
voyez le jour rapidement s'agissant du
laboratoire par exemple pfizer qui a
fait une annonce sur les résultats
préliminaires de son étude dite en
population générale
attention ce n'est pas terminé il ya que
94 patients du côté de la population non
vaccinée qui a eu le locaux vides donc
statistiquement c'est déjà parlant ce
qui est une bonne nouvelle mais nous
n'avons pas encore eu accès aux données
scientifiques à toutes les dates à il
faut ensuite que live dia et côté états
unis et l'agencé médicale agence
européenne du médicament puce avoir
connaissance de toutes les analyses
scientifiques pour statuer et déterminer
si oui ou non une autorisation de mise
sur le marché c'est à dire si on peut
commencer une campagne de vaccination ça
c'est un point important
d'autres laboratoires sont aussi sur le
point de faire des annonces sur
l'avancée de leurs travaux encore une
fois ce sera une excellente nouvelle que
le vaccin soit anglais américain ou un
jeu restera évidemment une très bonne
nouvelle pour la planète entière et face
à cela évidemment que nous nous
préparons pour débuter le plus tôt
possible une campagne vaccinale en
remplissant deux conditions que le
vaccin soit efficace avec le vaccin soit
sur nous quand nous ne commencerons pas
une campagne vaccinale contre le coc
vide
si nous n'avons pas la garantie que le
vaccin est à la fois efficace et sûre et
quand je vous dis que nous préparons
c'est que par exemple
s'agissant du vaccin commercialisé par
pfizer by one tech qui est aussi une
start up européennes l'europe ça compte
je peux le dire ah oui donc c'est
européen c'est un travail européen sur
ce vaccin qui nécessitent par exemple
d'être conservée à moins 80 degrés vous
allez me dire moins 80 degrés ça que ça
court pas les rues
nous avons d'ores et déjà acheté par
exemple c'est un exemple que je vous
donne 50 super congélateur qui
permettent de stocker à moins 80 degrés
des produits de santé qui sont reliés à
des alarmes qui seront entreposés dans
des dans des endroits sécurisés à partir
desquels des équipes vont se déployer
pour ensuite alimenter tous ceux qui
seront amenés à vacciner etc
c'est un chantier qui monumentale de
chercher la vaccination la haute
autorité de santé a communiqué en début
de semaine sur le fait qu'elle avait
démarré d'ailleurs une démarche à dire à
destination des citoyens pour renforcer
la démocratie sanitaire pour être
capable de déterminer quelles seraient
les conditions de cette vaccination
on va être amené en parlait beaucoup de
la vaccination c'est une bonne nouvelle
parce que ça veut dire que peut-être que
des vaccins peut-être que des vaccins
sont sur le point d'arriver et j'aurai
l'occasion de faire une
je ne sais pas sans doute pas de
conférence de presse haddock mais en
tout cas une communication plus arrêtée
sur cette question des différents
vaccins et de la façon dont nous
faisions nous envisageons les choses
mais rassurez-vous évidemment nous nous
y préparons
merci beaucoup mesdames et messieurs et
donc à très bientôt
vous m'entendez figure en live 19h17
nous sommes en direct après cette
annonce du gouvernement après deux
semaines de confinement eh bien on
attendait ou pas un resserrage de
wissous alors al'inverse peut-être un
allègement des différentes mesures de
confinement
et bien c'est un statut court comme on
pouvait le lire sur lefigaro il ya
quelques minutes après près d'un peu
plus d'une heure de discours de la part
est bien de jean castex le premier
ministre mais également bien sûr de
olivier v en ministre des solidarités et
de la santé de bruno le maire le
ministre de l'économie et de la relance
jean michel blanquer au ministre de
l'éducation nationale et enfin elisabeth
bornes la ministre du travail je vous
propose de débriefer en direct de de ces
annonces pour voir un petit peu ce qui a
été annoncé et ce que certaines choses
changent si d'autres noms je vois
notamment sur youtube vous êtes très
nombreux à nous poser des questions
en ce qui concerne la fermeture
potentielle des lycées et collèges et on
va revenir tous ensemble sur ces
différentes mesures avant cela un petit
salut dans le tchat
bonsoir à vous avec respect que je
retrouve régulièrement comme christian
léon crise jean paul ii également merci
d'être avec nous alice antheaume bonsoir
bonsoir
le truc ticks éditique série dia ou
encore vous haricots verts merci d'être
avec nous ce soir bonsoir sur twitch à
kinto merci de nous avoir rejoints en
début de cela et vous avez suivi avec
nous tout c'est toutes ces annonces vous
nous demandez s'il est possible d'avoir
un point général ben justement on va
leur faire tous ensemble je vais vous
faire un petit résumé
bonsoir fredi m lolilol 1975
bart live également merci à tous de nous
suivre
ulrich d'eau ou encore
vous skins live merci à vous d'être avec
no mercy a darkness 64 74 pour le follow
et enfin bonjour à tous sur youtube vous
êtes très nombreux à nous poser des
questions sur la fermeture des lycées et
collèges bas merci d'être avec nous je
vais vous faire un petit point là dessus
bonsoir à tout ce qu'ils nous disaient
bonsoir bonsoir les halls ou qui il ya
nosu georges pourrait pas tout société
vous êtes littéralement à des centaines
ce soir avec nous donc ce sera un peu
difficile mais bonsoir shadow miss les
arches en pin chantepie nonette anonyme
mybox bas merci à tous d'être avec no
mercy voilà si vous avez des questions
n'hésitez pas à nous les poser et bien
pour vous répondre au plus grand nombre
on va faire dans la priorité tout
d'abord est bien est ce que les lycées
et collèges fermés bien la réponse est
non il va falloir reprendre au même
rythme que ces deux dernières semaines
puisque le premier ministre a estimé
qu'il était souhaitable qu'une présence
à 100 % des élèves se fasse dans la
mesure où les établissements scolaires
et lycées pourrait bien assurer une
garantie des conditions sanitaires et
d'accueil des élèves voilà qui fera
peut-être plein de déçus sur youtube
mais voilà qui vous répond en tout cas
et qui évite la transition et le passage
de fausses nouvelles
là vous pouvez être sûr donc les lycées
et collèges ne ferme bel et bien pas ce
qu'on a appris également tout à l'heure
et bien c'était qu'un million deux cent
mille tests antigénique allait être
réservé aux au personnel enseignant qui
reste comme les personnels soignants
prioritaire pour les pour les tests
voilà qu'on voit là qui fut dit tout à
l'heure alors je vois beaucoup en tout
cas dans le tchad le message de
désolation sur la fermeture la non
fermeture des lycées et collèges
voilà il va falloir continuer d'y aller
avant les vacances de noël allez ça va
arriver très vite
courage n'hésitez pas à nous poser des
questions dans le chat si vous souhaitez
en savoir un peu plus alors s'il y a des
s'il y a des
s'il ya des questions à vraiment d'ordre
économique ou d'actualité bien je les
prend avec plaisir
voilà ce que l'on sait alors pour vous
répondre tinto qui nous demandait sur
twitch si l'on reste confinée aussi
déconfinement possible à partir du 1er
décembre date à partir de laquelle les à
l'école et le confinement devrait
prendre fin c'est ce que nous a rappelé
une nouvelle fois le gouvernement est
bien ce que l'on apprend c'est que c'est
que c'est que à partir du 1er décembre
pour moment c'est l'espoir qui prévaut
de la part du gouvernement un espoir et
qui le gouvernement qui est favorable à
une potentielle réouverture des
commerces dans la période de noël mais
en tout cas ce n'est que pour le moment
une position favorable et non une
annonce ce que l'on sait également est
bien c'est que ya ramené sain espoirs
d'assouplissement pour la période de
noël alors on pourrait s'attendre
toujours à une période de confinement
mais avec des règles un peu moins
strictes qui permettrait de se retrouver
en famille pour fêter la fin de l'année
voilà en tout cas pour pour cela ce que
l'on sait également est bien c'est que
certains chiffres que l'on a eue avec
par exemple 580 1000 contrôles qui ont
été faits depuis le 30 octobre 2010
depuis le 30 octobre
excusez moi alors en ce qui concerne les
contrôles et le respect du confinement
ce que l'on a appris plus tard au plus
tôt dans la journée c'est qu'un sondage
ifop pour consoler nous annonçait que
plus de la moitié des français aurait
transgressé les règles de confinement
depuis le 30 octobre
voilà alors est ce que vous vous
l'estimez respecter ce confinement est
ce que vous pensez que c'est un succès
en tout cas en ce que lorsque l'on peut
voir dans la rue
n'hésitez pas à nous le dire alors bon
soir au passage sur tweets chalet au bld
et avoue mme hind midi sur sur twitter
merci d'être d'être avec nous
je vois là donc pour noël ce que l'on
apprend donc c'est plutôt que le
gouvernement est dans l'espoir mais que
pour le moment on ne peut pas le savoir
il va falloir attendre bien les
prochaines semaines et de nouvelles
annonces pour avoir un peu plus de
chiffres et de statistiques qui nous
serait prometteur on l'espère pour cette
période de noël voilà ce que l'on a
appris alors après beaucoup de chiffres
je vous le disais de la part notamment
d'olivier ferrand le ministre de la
santé qui nous annonce est bien que
depuis le 1er octobre on compte pas
moins de quarante deux mille cinq cent
trente cinq morts au sein de nos
frontières qu'une hospitalisation et
compter toutes les 30 secondes en france
et que eh bien nous avons d'ores et déjà
dépassé le pic du mois d'avril un pic du
mois d'avril qui lui par contre ça ne
devrait pas un pic du mois d'avril mais
second pic qui lui devrait être atteint
bien pour la semaine prochaine donc il
va falloir rester vigilant sur les
différences statistiques qui sortiront
pour en savoir un peu plus sur cette
deuxième vague
ce que l'on sait également est bien
c'est que sept mille lits de réanimation
ont été armés par les autorités pour
accueillir un maximum de 1 malade
alors vous me dites que mon micro et
peut-être un peu trop fort je le recule
très légèrement excusez moi voilà
j'espère que c'est mieux n'hésitez pas à
me le dire dans le chatt normalement
c'est un peu mieux alors je vois aussi
beaucoup de questions notamment sur
youtube sur et bien la réouverture ou
pas des commerces notamment des
restaurants et bien pour moment non pas
du tout et pour les deux prochaines
semaines
au moins ce que l'on va apprendre et
bien c'est que d'ici au 1er décembre les
restaurants et commerces estimé non
essentiels ne rouvrons ne rouvrons pas
contrairement et bien à leur système de
livraison qui eux peuvent rester ouverts
mais on le sait très bien et bien c'est
toujours une situation très compliquée
pour les différents commerces non
essentiels qui sont maintenant fermés
depuis près de deux semaines voilà pour
ces différents chiffres
voilà je pense qu'on a fait un petit peu
le tour en tout cas de ce qui a été de
ce qui a été annoncé par le gouvernement
un peu de
un peu d'annoncés particulières ce que
l'on sait bien c'est que la situation
n'est simplement pas prête de changer
voilà pour pour pour cela voilà bah
merci en tout cas de vos commentaires là
je les lis au passage pendant que je
parle mais mais mais voilà on a fini ce
petit débriefing merci à vous de nous
avoir suivis je vais vous le rappeler
très légèrement est très rapidement pour
les personnes qui nous rejoindront alors
pas de changement particulier d'ici les
15 prochains jours
en revanche les lycées fermés les lycées
et collèges ne sont pas fermées comme
tous les ans les établissements
scolaires n'hésitez pas voilà à le
transmettre dans le chat si certaines
personnes nous rejoignent elles
également dans le temps dans le tchat ce
que l'on sait donc également c'est que
les commerces non essentiels resteront
bel et bien fermées pendant les deux
prochaines semaines jusqu'au 1er
décembre que et bien 45 % des salariés
du privé ont eu recours au télétravail
skis et ski et enfin ça c'était que la
semaine la semaine passée donc voilà
pour ce ce chiffre on a appris également
que 580 1000 contrôles avaient été
procédé depuis le 30 octobre et que et
bien le gouvernement espérait un
assouplissement pour la période de noël
mais que pour le moment rien n'était
encore à conclure
il va falloir attendre la prochaine là
les prochaines semaines pour savoir si
le pic de la seconde vague que l'on
connaît qui est d'ores et déjà plus
forte que la première sera bien bel et
bien atteint
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis je
vais vous saluer dans le chat avant de
se quitter
merci à vous kinto lolilol merci to be
light j'espère ne pas écorcher votre nom
les eaux
bld
merci it's my room body sur sur twitch
vous êtes nombreux
je vous souhaite une très bonne soirée
sur twitter je vous souhaite une très
bonne soirée également sur la homepage
du figaro bonsoir le truc jean paul 2
mais également avec respect ou encore
tic série dia je vous souhaite une bonne
soirée sur le figaro et enfin bonsoir à
tous avouent qu'ils nous regarder sur
youtube vous vous êtes toujours nombreux
et où je vous rappelle puisqu'il ya
encore beaucoup de personnes qui le
demandent les collèges lycées sont bel
et bien fermées tout comme les
restaurants et les commerces non
essentiels voilà pour ces infos ce
qu'ils sont un petit peu les deux ans
faute de la soirée qu'il faudra retenir
bon soir à lille snick sharkey chartis
lavender mauls mauvaise super sky qui
d'autre véronique l anonymat gosses m
voilà je ne pourrais pas tous vous
saluer mais le coeur y est
voilà très bonne soirée sur le figaro
n'hésitez pas à vous rendre sur la page
principale du figaro pour retrouver bien
les dernières grandes annonces du
gouvernement qui seront un peu plus
exhaustive que ce que l'on a pu faire
ici et bien on se dit à très vite pour
un nouveau stream sur figaro live